well if you've been to an event on the
strip or gone shopping around town it
may be difficult to spot people wearing
a mask since only 53 percent of people
in the county have their first vaccine
shot
this is some some concern for many
people kate houston went to the
southwest valley
to see how shoppers feel about that
disparity and how the state
is now responding i think it's really
important to wear a mask
as covid 19 cases and hospitalizations
rise
health officials are pushing for
unvaccinated people to keep their mask
on i believe you should vaccinated or
not vaccinated especially if you have
pre-existing condition and also
with the new strains coming out but some
are noticing the amount of people
wearing a mask is not matching the high
amount of people who are unvaccinated
there's a lot of people who are taking
advantage of the change in mandates but
i think it's important
that we try to make the you know
pace as we go as safe as possible victor
de la cruz is vaccinated but continues
to wear a mask in crowded areas
there's like elderly and people who
can't get vaccinated so i just think
wearing a mask
is important to just helping the
community in a way to do that
so as positivity rates climb will the
state fall back on previous covet 19
safety protocols like mandated masks
michelle white with the governor's
office says their focus is on vaccines
in order to embrace that feeling of
protection and relief
one must be vaccinated some though say
they wouldn't mind
tighter restrictions for peace of mind
i've seen them do it in california right
now my cousin from there she's just
telling me that they're bringing it back
i'm honestly okay with it like i'm going
to sam's club right now i don't mind
wearing the mask it's never been really
a big deal for me
if everyone just could wear the masks
and keep
if i'm spreading them we don't have to
shut down again i don't want to ever see
that
happen to us kate houston 8 news now
kate thanks right now clark county has
control over covid mitigation efforts
we reached out to them for a statement
on mass restrictions and at this time
have not heard back